[Music]
infolding man news submitted by a count
your blessings a man who spent decades
with his face stuck to his thighs can
finally stand up straight wait
Oh in the border of the last article it
was like wait I hope to cover that
decades decades you like sy amis to
himself
can he commit like flesh wise like that
good here does he have no ribs
you guys are children can you do what
Jolie dreams of doing okay so this 46
year old man he has spent the last three
decades of his life with his face
pressed against his thighs because he
has this rare condition it's called a s
and so he ended up actually I think I
just gonna [ __ ] us up right ankylosing
spondylitis ass those [ __ ] dicks man
the doctors coming up with that [ __ ]
they're like we're Latin no you're not
so he got diagnosed with that when he
was 18 years old do I see what that
looks like can I please see this picture
it's driving me absolutely crazy well I
hope it keeps driving you crazy I'm not
gonna show you the more you ask love
less I will and I can see it as I hope
the audience can see it eventually the
audience has already seen it because the
editor don't drag me down with him [ __ ]
don't drag me down with Steve I want to
know but I didn't have airplane mode
joke no he's got a he's on he's [ __ ]
with us man this is the video where TIFF
is just making some [ __ ] up and then
they're all in on it
and we're all
that picture looks like a joke did you
saw it it looks fake it looks like
something I would send my mom and like
oh no I'm stuck mom what do I do
looks like something I would prank my
mom with yeah it's pretty wild I can't
wait till you see Incan people
discovered when you watch the video sure
hope I could see it sooner
all right so he's from China Li hua is
from China and so he had never liked his
family was always too poor to afford any
type of treatments and so not until he
got the attention of this one particular
doctor then that's when this doctor was
like we gotta help him
doctors walking by the other doctors
[Laughter]
great because now this person's not real
ii mean i can do all the bits I want
motor you know circus toys they pretty
much I was trying to hold it so Stephen
yes you know it's crazy in order to help
this man they said that they had to
achieve like the medical world's
equivalent of climbing Mount Everest
whoa I thought cancer was that care
encounter for his spine like spinal work
Oh
in this field all of medicine unfolding
this dude we have climbed Everest yeah
I'm falling this dude and then a couple
doctors got stuck up there I don't think
the joke works you know why because I
don't think this is a real person
because I haven't seen it so but then
the jokes are kind of missing the mark
yeah it would be dead let me tell you so
they said the only option to help him
was to break his bones one section at a
time one femur cervical vertebrae
thoracic vertebrae lumbar vertebrae and
then it ended up helping out that one is
lace yeah it's his femur what the [ __ ]
yes so do this
did he suck his own dick oh I will tell
you I'll just cry to you what this man
had to suffer with yeah I'll try to
picture it with my eyes closed his
severe spinal deformity was described as
three on chin to chest Stern looks like
a paperclip we don't see a little bit of
fishing that huh and face to femur he'll
never be able to fix it okay God go draw
what you see draw weight you see so does
this kind of like see people it's called
causing [ __ ] oh yeah for sure
nobody's ever seen people cuz that's
true I've seen people do the other side
slow down yeah he lives in an
upside-down world oh I can't wait to see
what you [ __ ] see yeah probably not
what did we see this guy ever smoked
weed if I had some way faster nothing
works here let's continue while he tries
to figure it out well I want to see
silver they're saying that in order for
them to to do this whole procedure that
they knew that there was this really
extremely high risk of paralysis yeah
he's breaking all of his spine holy [ __ ]
so but they were saying that by not
operating on him he would be in mortal
danger because the pressure on his heart
and lungs was
more than a person can bear well if you
keep standing like that of course your
mind even I get down put it the other
way that's Spongebob me we're just like
what if we to see luckily oh wait [ __ ]
you guys I do the Wu Tang simple well
I'm the head I said terrible yeah that
looks like the little throw thing simple
are you ready
close your eyes first they're closed
they're closed wait hold on ready are
you ready
do you Lisa
alright Pharrell's here we go something
always said my mom yeah how does it PPE
I don't know they don't tell me I'll be
quit the answers to the questions that
we only can see like you see where it
opponent that guy needs to stop standing
and sit down
Oh cuz his chin is touching his oh my
god so how does the blood not rush to
his head all the time
how was he born leakin although we don't
remember at 1800 when he started folding
no that's just how he started just
growing from 18 and on like his spine
started deforming so much yeah
but luckily that the operation was a
success Wow
to feel good one oh my god that's his
face yeah that's what he looks like
see oh my goodness
and is he gonna be able to walk himself
yeah so right now they have he he's
being helped by the walker but they're
saying that eventually he won't need it
and he'll be perfectly fine he's a
miracle man that's why they call not a
lot of oh man did that first picture it
literally looks like it's faces his
balls like really honest nuts that's
crazy
is he like five billion dollars in debt
no okay cuz they were like yo if we pull
this off right it cools [ __ ] yeah cuz it
follows like this and they told me the
bills five billion I'm like we have to
stay like bar it's all like I got
another couple centimeters to go before
it really measured 90 centimeters in
height how much is that imagine being
this guy he's less than three feet tall
wait 90 right yeah yep you're this guy
you this guy you've recovered you're
sitting at a bus station you hear people
complaining about their lives are you
just like do you just look at my face
we're [ __ ] three-decker without a
picture there's this old man I think he
might be old because of the way he is
but like he lives in our neighborhood
and I always see him like sometimes
carrying grocery bags and stuff but he's
like yeah like this like insanely yeah
just like 90-degree angle right yeah
where I'm like before man but he kind of
looks like the kind of guy that if I
would try to go up to him and s like do
you need help you doing no I got it he's
probably like already pissed off with
the world cuz he doesn't look like a
very approachable friendly kind of
person well he could be you know this is
just like the guy and home along with
the snow shovel it's look pretty
welcoming there's no supple guy mm-hmm
well he actually turned out to be a very
nice yeah I judged him that way from the
beginning I was like he's probably nice
you're so cool
the home loan - bird lady was [ __ ]
scary just scary uh there she like she
smelled she's covered in [ __ ] bird
shits why she looks like she smelled
remember when he gave her turtle does
and it's like what the [ __ ] am I gonna
do with these Wow you're the judge you
know it's like what is she gonna do with
him [ __ ] eat them can't even hang it up
hey thanks for spoiling home long to
friend oh I haven't seen it
yeah round hit of the summer these guys
are like one of those airplane neck
pillow so she could [ __ ] what you
sleeping on their balconies I walk I
think we all should be okay fair point
fair point well the birds in your back
which need a [ __ ] pillow for a lumbar
support because yeah her [ __ ] I
[Music]
[ __ ] a big attention to this [ __ ] you
say
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]